hey guys welcome back to the evident
caitlyn podcast the podcast where you
come for the freshest and hottest
youtube tea water you didn't warn me
that that's not what you were opening
with we'll be back right back okay we're
back and Caitlyn has her fresh tea
prepared tea I come with tea so today
we're gonna be talking about YouTube
some updates on copyright systems some
drama that's going on and I don't know
actually Caitlyn prepared this pocket I
did I prepared this tea today okay yeah
so some recent interesting YouTube
updates potentially good things
potentially bad things and then we have
a game that is inspired by a game that I
listened to on the Jenna Julian podcast
where they did Florida man or not which
basically there's like a subreddit
called Florida man and it's I don't go
too far into the details because this is
their game but it's a bunch of headlines
so it's Florida man you know gets
stalked by alligator that's a really
lame one you usually they're funny and
so Julian presented a series of Florida
man headlines that were real and were
fake and Jenna had to guess yeah I did
the same thing today but it's called
youtuber headline or not mmm and so I
found some youtuber headlines that were
real and I made some of my self and
you're gonna have to guess which ones
are real and which ones are fake I'm
gonna get a hundred percent on when the
passed this test yeah I think yeah we'll
get into we can get into some of the
interesting updates because some of them
one of them has affected us a decent
about decent amount and that's copyright
claim stuff yeah and if you like are
surrounded by the YouTube stuff like we
are you obviously heard of this but if
you haven't heard of this copyright
claim this are a big current issue on
YouTube sometimes they're being used
properly sometimes they're being abused
usually abuse yeah yeah so basically
when we as content creators create a
piece of content
we put a lot of work into it we we do
the filming the scripting the editing or
whatever it needs you know every channel
is different but we put in all this time
to make a video now there's two things
that can happen one if you are a big
company like Sony you can like put your
music within YouTube system and say hey
if you ever match this song let us know
and we can claim it so that's one thing
the automatic yeah and then a lot of
these companies they have people
manually watching youtube videos and
then if they detect if like the person
hears or sees anything about that video
that they think is copyrightable they
will claim it so it's like if in the
background like we're in the mall and
we're walking along and the radio is
playing a song that we don't have the
rights to technically like a company
like Sony or Warner Brothers or whatever
can claim our entire video in various
ways yeah I feel like like even if it
was a legit claim I feel like they
should only get a proportion of the
money that like that song is in so if
the song is in 1 percent of the video
that you only get one percent that's not
how it works man
but the the main issue is a lot of
people will leave false claims yeah so
they'll they'll the one that we've had
done done to us before is so crazy it's
pretty good as possible we like we we
have some artists that we support on
patreon or we used to we've since
switched from doing this method of
gathering music because this has
happened but we had artists that we
supported on patreon and you know it's
just like a patreon agreement that we
have the rights to use their music by
supporting them mm-hmm but what's
happened is these companies have made
like bogus albums where they'll take
artists music add bad rap lyrics aren't
just terrible just terrible and they'll
just record it directly over various
artists music put it in an album on like
Google Play and stuff and then say that
they own the copyright yeah so every
time this happened we've been able to
like fight the copyrights that you know
say we know who the original artist is
the person making this claim doesn't
own it we have permission to use it blah
blah blah it's a huge pain and like it
it's basically up to the copyright claim
er to say okay okay you got me isn't a
real time you can use it but we don't
really have any power you don't have
almost yeah it's like if someone claims
one of our videos and we dispute that
and we say no it's fair use or we have
the rice or whatever if they say no you
don't then the only way to like move
forward is to take it to court I believe
you have like go to the courts to like
defend the rights to your own thing that
you created yep and and you know
sometimes there have been like legit
mistakes that were kind of made like on
one of the songs that we used we were
supporting the artist the artist said
that he created it and he did but
underlying in that song were it was like
a tempo or a beat or something it was
sampled from it wasn't even sampled the
sampling is where like they'll take and
actually like bit from and include it in
there's this was there was a certain
like part of a song with a certain like
tune in lyrics and the artists we
supported had another singer singing it
it was in a totally different style but
it was like the same few lyrics in a
similar mo different different tune and
we got copy struck by like Warren or
something we didn't even know that that
like those words and that tune came from
anything but if there's a reason that
you guys don't hear the like cool kind
of old-school swing beats on our channel
anymore it's because we were paranoid
about that happening again so now we
like only use certain types of music but
anyways that the update to this there's
been a couple so in July they chained it
to where like you're Content ID claims
if people are doing them they have to be
time-stamped yep
and if the people making the claim don't
like provide accurate data they can get
blocked from doing any more claims yep
and YouTube says they introduced tool
like editing tools to remove or replace
the music they suck they suck so bad
like zoom in on your timeline you just
have to you know if you have a 20 minute
video you have to like try to get the
correct start and stop point we tried to
do it it was tough we weren't able to
but then the the more interesting update
and this is so all that was kind of
background yeah more interesting update
is now they say that incidental clips
which is like background at a store and
there's radio going on in the background
or very short clips which they don't
define they just a very short can still
be claimed but not for revenue which the
theory is that these companies that are
manually claiming it they have to hire
people or pay somebody to be watching
all these YouTube videos looking for it
because it's worth it to them cuz then
they make revenue but if they're not
making revenue maybe they'll stop doing
that and they'll just leave creators
alone but the downside is that the the
options are like they can block the
creator from making money so we could
still not make money mmm or they can
block the video entirely yeah and so the
worry is that in the short term there
will be more videos that are just
blocked entirely and the crazy thing is
some channels use the same intro music
and the same outro music and the really
really scary thing is some channels like
that they'll have 200 videos they'll
have a large channel they'll have worked
years and years to build up this channel
and everything and all of a sudden if
someone says hey this this music that
you used in your intro you didn't have
the full copyright aspects to it and
it's very confusing and hard to like
know that for sure
and fully be able to trust in people
that say like yeah yeah you can use this
but like if you have that and every
single of your intros your entire
library could just be gone yeah
it's terrifying it's terrifying it's
like a wild wild west on YouTube
sometimes yeah yeah it's like now we
only have two music sources and they're
both proven legit yeah ok and I'm what
kind of like looking through your
outline here I have an even more update
on this
yeah YouTube is actually suing someone
for abusing the copyright system we
might have been watching it at the same
time like it but it's setting a
precedent so if they successfully sue
this person and it's just like a random
person not even that it's not like a
huge company or anything but they've
been repeat repeat offenders to multiple
channels they keep changing their
username but it's all traced back to the
same person making all these bogus
claims and trying to like hold things
ransom yeah but if they succeed that
should if they succeed in suing them
then that should hopefully prevent other
people from doing it because then it
shows it's like defendable in court yeah
yeah it's crazy it is scary because yeah
I think that in a way the old system
where you just like lost your
monetization or you ended up sharing the
monetization that's not too scary it's
annoying it's upsetting but it's not
that scary I mean losing your
monetization is pretty scary losing I'm
scared like cuz there goes like your
incoming you know what's even more scary
is if all of a sudden you just start
losing videos yeah that's scary that's
the worst case scary scenario yeah
that's that's terrifying to me yeah I
know but like I guess the the thought is
like we have gotten kind of both aspects
of this we have gotten the legit claim
from a legit music person lera like you
know company like hey in one of the
songs you used our underlying beat
melody was used in that so you can't use
that and we're like honest mistake sorry
I guess we lose monetization no big deal
I mean it is a big deal but it's like
not that bad but what if like we had
just been going about a day and all of a
sudden one of our most popular videos is
just gone because of like a very honest
simple mistake that we made with no
mal-intent
it's like we're trying our best to
follow these complicated rules like put
you know call me maybe in the song like
in the video and get away with it
pirating music and re uploading our own
music videos of them to try to get money
off of the music no no we're like the
music is a very incidental part of this
and it's not even like I hate
like call people out but like there are
some channels that use music as a big
part of their videos like I know that
Ella Mills has talked about her use of
copyrighted music in her videos before
she very openly doesn't she was very
open he doesn't she's like you know what
it's the mood that I was going for I
couldn't think of another song I just
had to do it and I tried to like
minimize the amount of seconds that it
was playing and like that was kind of it
you know she she honestly like the music
is kind of an integral part of her and
for us it's like just background frozen
[ __ ] background it's like sometimes like
don't worry about it I do think if
YouTube makes their tools better like
yeah I would replace it with your own
audio because right now the only thing
you can replace like if there's a
segment of your video that has
infringing music in it the only thing
you can replace it with are other
musical songs from the YouTube audio
library if you're talking during that
scenes then and you replace it with
music then it'll just be your mouth
music oh no can you add like text on top
of this I was like sorry guys header a
change like the only tools that YouTube
has is replace music blares and edit out
that chunk you could just remove that
time you jump forward in time of it it's
not the best but I mean like I you know
we have been part of like the like a
legit claim it was an honest mistake but
it was a legit claim from a legit
company but more claims we've had have
been bogus more claims we've had have
been bogus it's like they're in Fury
completely bogus claims it's like look
we're we're channel is doing this this
is our business and there's just some
like Punk out there that's trying to
like it is a youth somewhere he's like
you know I'm just gonna start a side
hustle and I'm just gonna create all
these gonna rap terribly over all these
and then I'm just gonna claim it on all
these other like you know companies and
small channels they don't know how to
fight against it they don't know what
because it's a confusing thing to fight
against so a lot of companies are a lot
of people probably we did do a lot of
digging to find that they're like bogus
saying cuz the first we're like well if
the person were support
maybe maybe they did like take a sample
from this person song and it's legit so
you have to like go and dig around and
find it and yeah you have to do a lot of
internet sleuthing is that a rule yes
sleuthing yeah meddling kids
yeah and we're pretty good sleuths yes
we're pretty good sloths and we sloth
that out real good
but I know I'm not but I mean so it's
like at least YouTube is trying thing
that's out you know I'll give them
credit there cuz they are trying to
balance it out cuz like there's no way
that they can be the arbiter on all of
these cases ya know no they can't and I
think they're trying I think like it's
just gonna take time to work all the
kinks out and I hope that there's not I
mean there's already been casualties
along the way hope it doesn't get
drastically worse yeah like while
they're working things out another
interesting thing and this has been
resolved but I just thought it was
interesting another piece of like
YouTube news is that YouTube started
flagging robot fighting videos as animal
cruelty what and what okay sounds US
animal or robot fighting okay so I just
a little background I learned about this
from Angus makers Muse mm-hm so I saw
his video posted on Twitter and then I
watched the video super interesting so
um we can link to that he scooted me
over I'm at a-frame he goes into a lot
more detail about it but basically any
type of like BattleBots type videos oh
wow a lot of people from the battle
actual battle bots teams will upload
their videos and those are some of the
ones that some of the examples he showed
because they posted like the emails they
got from youtube but the interesting
thing is what the email says is that you
know their video has been flagged by the
youtube system and upon review it's been
determined that this video is not
suitable because of animal cruelty then
it gives examples like dogfighting and
cockfighting upon review but it said
upon review which is like that's the
thing it's like obviously and I will say
they've since remedied this they've gone
back all the
but the videos were just getting taken
down taken down removed yeah they were
blocked like people's videos were just
gone the and then they've since been
reinstated no email from YouTube or
anything they were just back after this
kind of blew up on Twitter yeah um but
yeah that's the weird thing is that it
said upon review
so someone supposedly supposedly said
yes so that that means one of two things
one the people that they're reviewing
aren't reviewing or they say upon review
but it's just an algorithm this is now
Griffin reviewing it's not interesting
because when you see like when you
request manual review and your thing
gets like D monetize and you're like oh
there's nothing in here manual review
you assume it's a person yeah maybe it
is but maybe well there's another whole
thing there's like a hidden brain
episode on it about people caring more
and more about robots because robots are
like you know robots can and you know
they can express themselves now and they
can you know you know people start
caring about robots so it's like yeah so
it's like if you built up within a video
like like they're caring like if you
with the viewer built up an empathetic
relationship with a robot and at the end
you destroyed it
is that like cruelty being shown it's
not animal cruelty but like will it
become in the future when robots can
like you know when people can form
connections to robots will it become
like something that is that suitable
yeah let's notice like imagine like a
tickle-me-elmo to ten point oh we're
like Elmo it can like like recognize
your face and say like hi Evan how are
you doing today and like you can talk
with it because that's becoming like
within the realm of possibility now like
facial recognition
you know advanced algorithms and stuff
for interacting with with robots voice
recognition and everything so what if in
a video you like have this robot be a
character and at the end you destroy it
is that suitable for four I think it's
probably fine because okay think of um
oh shoot what's the same Andre he's like
a the animation channel we watched a lot
of like YouTube drama type animations oh
yeah he's got um Wilford his purple duck
goose yeah friend this is all animated
but sometimes like Wilfred gets shot oh
yeah so it's all done in like skit form
with the animation but that's a
fictional animal character that's not
really alive and he's not getting fired
so I think something that would still be
fine I think that like a line has to be
drawn yeah but it's interesting because
there there are lots of lines being
drawn all over the place and they're all
very blurry yeah cuz like it is a tough
problem to address there's the jillian's
of hours of YouTube content being
uploaded all the time and YouTube has to
rely on algorithms and algorithms are
gonna continually fail yeah and this
might sound like we're like complaining
about YouTube we're not really
complaining like YouTube is awesome and
I think like they're doing the best they
can for most things and this completely
points out why YouTube is one of the
main like the only video service out
there like this because they're the only
ones that can try to address these
problems because no matter what website
there is there are gonna be these issues
yeah you know yeah if you get big enough
you're gonna face these especially when
there's money involved money is the
thing that complicates the whole no
one's gonna do it yeah that's like
that's like what's that that video site
that starts to the V like a meow Vimeo
savvy me oh there's no inherent
monetization there's no I think you have
to pay them to upload if you want to
upload more than a certain amount of
videos per month or certain gigabyte or
whatever it's like you have to pay your
videos yeah so on that side you don't
hear about controversies ever because
there's no shenanigans to be had and
YouTube is where the shenanigans are
because you can make a lot of money on
YouTube and everyone goes crazy over
that yeah it's like can't we all just
decide to be like this try to do our
best honest there's all the honest human
being is unless like not a
use the systems because when people try
to abuse things that's when rules have
to be put in place that harm everyone
else yep yep my brain now you know what
isn't complicated and there is no drama
around what squarespace because when you
host a website on Squarespace you don't
have to do the maintenance you don't
have to install any plugins or updates
or anything like that
we host our podcasts on Squarespace we
host our channel website on Squarespace
and you know how much get so much
madness we've had to do there
how much none because it just works and
having website there's a really
important part of many people's
businesses you know so if you want to
sell products you can do that on
Squarespace if you want to host a
portfolio you can do that on Squarespace
if you want to if you your business is
some sort of service and people need to
book appointments yeah you could do that
on Squarespace they were all these
different like fancy integrations that
you would think like oh I need to hire a
web designer to do this custom for me no
but it's all built-in so built-in little
third-party plugins needed and 24/7
support pretty cool so if you are
interested in getting your own square
scrub Squarespace website and want to
take the plunge into having the legit
website head over to squarespace.com
slash Evan Kaelin podcasts yep for 10%
off your first purchase I saw it coming
but I didn't stop it it was good okay
okay yes pretty smooth
okay you want to talk about YouTube okay
okay excited to do this okay so we
already kind of explained it oh yeah
we'll do the music
[Music]
don't can't forget that okay so I'm
really curious hit me okay
don't look at the screen I'm not I'm
gonna be looking at the camera do you
guys see my eyes going away I'm cheating
I'm just gonna drink while looking at
you okay
so I'm not gonna tell you how many real
headlines I have or how many fake
headlines I have oh my gosh what if
they're all fake they could be or they
could be how do you devious I was doing
a lot of research yesterday so you know
you don't know I don't know okay I will
say that only of the you know ones that
I was looking at I only actually
recognized one of the youtubers which oh
it just makes me realize there are a lot
of youtubers out there yeah yeah and I
will also preface this by saying that
like no shade at torts any of the
youtubers and the headlines I was
googling what was out there
yeah and picked ones that I thought
would be fun for the occasion you shade
its from the algorithm okay six year old
youtuber buys nine point five billion
dollar house with profits from
controversial Tory review channel how
old six six year old so that's that's
not Ryan Toya reviews because he is
older now he is about nine and billion
I'll read it again
six-year-old youtuber by is nine point
five billion dollar house with profits
from controversial toy review channel oh
gosh
I give this a fifty fifty percent chance
because there are like there's a lot of
money to be had in those kids toy review
channels like Ryan it's pays away the
highest paying channel or the highest
paid youtuber on YouTube is a kid he
does toy reviews and stuff and other
comment yes essentially means his
parents like well does it go to a trust
in his name that his parents can
withdraw from or maybe depends on how
the channel was started was it started
cuz like Ryan was like mom and dad I
really want to make youtube videos when
there's like I'm sure you or was their
parents saying like you know Frank I
think this would be a great I was
listening to the dad's name is Frank I
think this would be a great investment
opportunity we should start making these
videos our kids super
you look at Ryan yeah I don't know he's
always reviewing toys anyways
money money money money money yeah I
don't know yeah that kind of goes into a
whole another question about YouTube and
like because with well knows with TV
there are rules and regulations on who
gets the profit how the parents can use
it and how much worked worked and stuff
like that and there's like strict
regulations all the way until they're 18
I think no no no there's no like people
like overseeing the parents and how they
yeah you know have their kids spend
their time and everything okay that's a
that's a whole nother thing we're not
going there oh yes very careful you can
always tell when Evan steps because it's
very audibly loud okay the tea you told
me it is true and the answer is it is
true oh the tea told me okay
so I'll give you so a little bit of
information so happen this headline was
from a few weeks ago it's a South Korean
youtuber named Boram Wow or the channel
I don't know if that's her name or
there's a channel name but it's a little
girl and the controversy is that there's
several staged clips and her channel
we're like very questionable things are
happening so the examples given are one
a staged clip where she's like stealing
money a staged clip where she's driving
a car and a staged clip where she's
giving birth what yeah so there's like
weird staged clips which is I guess why
its controversial again we don't never
heard of this channel before this I'm
sure it was in your article that's
pushing that's pushing it like push it
but yeah 9.5 billion dollar house but
then it's also like it's weird cuz it's
like six year old youtuber buys this
house but it's like is she buying it
she's not I don't think she was like mom
and dad I really want this house and
they're like whatever you want baby to
your money yeah sure let you know and
it's not like the six-year-old is coming
up with those clips you know someone is
you know she's like I think it's
controversial cuz like the parents are
I'm assume
running the show yeah because she's six
and that's like weird that's weird it's
weird yeah yeah so that was that was a
real one man okay next one this time I'm
gonna have the tea ready you tell me
you'll tell me okay
YouTube diver finds GoPro camera near
waterfall containing man's final moments
alive I'm gonna swirl the tea mm-hmm it
is absolutely true because I saw that
and I read it ah dang it
sorry read it read it spoiled it for me
I don't know the details crazy he's a
smaller youtuber
I'm his name is rich Aloha and he does
kind of like outdoorsy adventure II type
stuff I believe his channel is like I
don't know like 11k
or something like that um and this was
from five days ago but yeah he was just
doing a video and he found this GoPro
and I had a man who had who had died I
guess exploring though he was near a
waterfall I don't know exactly what
happened but it was like footage of like
this man and his friends like having a
good time on the trip oh man yeah so I
guess now the family has it so they have
these like moments where he was happy
but also it's like like that's like
that's some heavy footage to have you
know it's like but it's crazy because
the GoPro was was I believe in water
like he was diving yeah I found it but
it's fully functional memory card and
all this stuff I guess it wasn't a
waterproof case man too bad GoPro can't
use that for a commercial because that'd
be bad that that's a bad that's a bad
that's a bad thing
oh boy super to the tee has told me
reddit yeah okay 89 year old woman
starts youtube channel playing elder
scrolls gains 1 million subscribers in
less than a year that is true and that
lady's awesome and I've also seen that
unread it
that's not her what no I made up the
facts what is an old woman that plays
elder scrolls yeah she's like she's like
known as a gamer grandma yeah yeah but I
just made up all these numbers oh oh I
knew you would see that one on reddit
but I knew you wouldn't know the details
so that one's kind of sneaky oh oh man
the tee has failed me you just you
assumed everything was true that was
thank you though
that was bellows because there is gamer
hitting me with the details you know
yeah well I got a these headlines were
much more detailed than I expected huh
like many more words Wow in a headline
so I had to get detailed okay okay cool
yeah I was so confident I is your - you
ready what who's ready beauty youtuber
encourages fans to harass urban decay on
Twitter results in lawsuit there's a lot
of attack culture going on right now I
know it's like I know it's like cancel
culture I kind of think of it as more of
attack culture yeah sometimes there's
cancel like within the intent but
sometimes it's just like hey attack this
person and it's bad yeah I think it's
like it was just like like personal
feuds
it's a dangerous precedent to kind of go
down a pond you know it's like and I'm
guessing it was on Twitter if it's real
you don't need to verify or deny but by
like Twitter is like the main place
where those attacks kind of spread
because of the retweet you know and all
of that like Twitter is where like
things really go viral or read it but
reddit will not stand for that type of
crap rather be like who cares go away
we'll kind of gang up on people but only
if it's a small person promoting it this
outside of the situation if a big person
is telling them oh no like self-guided
if reddit decides amongst itself yeah
that somebody needs to be cancelled or
attacked or whatever they'll do it yeah
for sure because like a youtuber told
them to yeah the tea already told me
is true oh god oh so so was all of it
fake or was I just made urban decay is
like one of the only makeup brands that
I know of because I have some urban
decay stuff and I was like oh but
putting a an actual brand in there will
make it seem like legit and it seems
like some kind of drama that okay you
completely got me on now and I give you
full credit you have one and a half
points thank you wait female gaming
youtuber raises 50,000 for charity by
shaving her head on camera false oh wait
I didn't take Missy the way of it I'm
double guessing myself let me know if
you want me to read it again it's still
false
I just wanted to put one in that was
positive yeah all of these are negative
and I was like that'd be really cool but
a female like gamer shaved her head
raised $50,000 that'd be very bold I
mean some people might not be as bold
for some people like let's say you
already have like short hair so so well
I wonder how would be so it's like so
she starts out with a full head of hair
and every square inch is like $1,000
because then you could like shave a
square inch which would still be
devastating to your haircut and when it
gets to the fifty you shave it in
celebration the whole thing at once oh
yeah I mean you'd have to be ready for
it yeah you have to know what's coming
oh man we were at your we are not your
family's house and for some reason we're
watching a fear factor cousins we're
showing us some Fear Factor clips on you
yeah and there's one now a popular thing
apparently or I don't know this is
recent or not we have launched for your
faction a long time but the punishment
or the thing you have to do is shave
your head and and she had a very hard
time with her this would theoretically
be different situations yeah
volunteering to do yeah yeah you know
you already have like a pixie cut or
something you know yeah it's only like 4
more months until it regains like maybe
I should have done male youtuber but I
feel like that wouldn't be that big of a
deal yeah that did that'd be cool that'd
be cool
like our principal would shave his head
you know things like that at school oh
my gosh what if someone shaved their
beard though yeah I should have done
like made it a male instead of a female
to make that one more believable because
it wouldn't it need to be more money for
maybe someone had had really bad press
and they were trying to like make up for
and she wouldn't do it okay ready for
the next yes I have my tea ready okay
beauty youtuber addresses complaints
over moldy and hairy lipsticks
oh that's completely true I heard about
it there's there's a youtuber that that
uh had hairy lipsticks and she didn't
address without that well like people
are still upset with her even though she
tried to address it yeah that one
actually just that's the only one I knew
about Jaclyn hill is the youtuber this
happened two months ago there's another
one like Jojo Cu or something like that
was different
there's like asbestos in her eyeshadow
yeah and she like made this very joking
apology video that wasn't even an
apology video about it like hey hey
don't worry about it it's cool yeah I
knew because we had watched something on
that one together so I knew you knew
that one yeah I figured you might knew
this one but I wanted to throw in
testing my depth of knowledge yeah this
is the only one that I had heard about
ahead of time I'm excited to turn the
tables on you and quiz you on YouTube
headlines yeah yeah next time next time
what we're going to say I was just gonna
say apparently she liked her Jaclyn had
to like cancel her Twitter and stuff for
a while well it was doing so much okay
yeah which is again Gary I mean yeah the
product should be good but also like
it's scary the backlash yeah I mean like
a lot of youtubers that we've talked to
they've said like a very common refrain
that we hear is you get all this
positive feedback and we really
appreciate all of the feedback you give
especially the 5-star reviews and I
but thank you so all of the positive
feedback helps and it helps boost this
up and it helps us like know like yes
we're doing this for the right reason is
where people are enjoying this or it's
making people stay is better but those
negative comments really do stand out to
a lot of people and if you're getting an
onslaught of negative comments yeah so
if people we know have a hard time was
just a small amount of a graffiti back
what if the majority was negative that'd
be really hard I mean and she did mess
up but it could have been I could I
don't know her at all I don't even know
who she is or what her content is if
she's a nice person or not but like
again with bigger scandal it could have
been a much bigger scandal but also what
if she was approached by a brand that
she trusted and they said hey would love
to make something with you and she's
like oh well I trust you go for it and
you can put my name on it she trusted
them to do to do well enough and then
she gets all of the backlash when
another company or another person messed
up yeah I mean again I don't know that I
don't know the situation at all there's
a lot of something that happens there's
a lot of these dangers that you have to
address you know and I guess that's why
you know you really have to get involved
and you have to have the time and
ability to really dive in like we know
someone else who launched her own
cosmetic thing and she tested it and
reviewed it and like worked with a
company who's producing it for years on
R&D and quality and everything before
she launched it so it's like I guess
that's the way you go about it if you're
gonna go about responsibly even if you
trust them trust the double check trust
but verify something like cosmetics is a
lot trickier than if you're doing like a
you know merch or something because
there's like health issues with
cosmetics too so it's like yeah the
quality of your t-shirt might not be as
good as people hoped but it's not like
asbestos in your eyeshadow yeah like
your children's eyeshadow so you know
levels okay okay so that was that was
the easy one I threw in there just in
case you were horrible at this game and
needed a win but you're doing pretty
good thank you thank you the faith
I didn't know you know thanks on my
music skills you might have been right
to doubt me good job
okay you ready I'm ready family vlogger
with more than 2.5 million subscribers
accidentally admits to having fourth
child for channel growth just thinking
about all of the implications of that my
gosh it's like Majan being the kid i was
mainly thinking of the kid it's like I
exist because my parents wanted to grow
their channel I didn't choose bring me
into this world for the right reasons
yeah Wow it's totally believable that
someone would do that in this current
environment which is bad
it's Budong it's bad wrong it's bad
wrong so it's badonk for sure but is it
real like it's it's such a believable
headline unfortunately it's so sad so
I'm gonna have to say yes because I mean
we they're real life examples where
stuff has leaked accidentally online and
yeah I believe it it's false oh but
isn't it crazy that it was that
believable it was it was completely
believable I should have said like no no
one would do that but like I'd be lying
if I didn't believe that that was a real
headline it's crazy that's crazy okay
well pour one out for the poured out
into my mouth this isn't pouring it out
at all I'm ready for another don't fail
me now to you pet tuber shocks the
internet with taxidermy of beloved
deceased sugar glider whoa oh my gosh
that's I mean I'm going back and forth
because some people who like animals
have taxidermy done but it would be
controversial what if like you're used
to like seeing this thing and loving it
and it's alive and you have a connection
to it and all of a sudden it's like on
the wall yeah still I mean ever I've
only met one taxidermist in real life
and he freaking loved animals
he loved animal no she was taxidermist
yeah like it seems so most of them like
loved animals
yeah and then some taxidermist like
really get like meaning in life because
people come to them wanting to like you
know to the people who want taxidermy of
their animals they want that and it
brings joy to them in a way just like
the taxidermist are bringing joy to the
people they're the clients but I think
it's something that a lot of people feel
very uncomfortable about feel very
uncomfortable about yeah here one more
time pet tuber shocks the internet was
taxidermy of beloved deceased sugar
glider Bhatia is telling me that it's
true it's false oh my gosh Kaitlin how
you are really good at this like in the
beginning I was like yeah yeah but like
that's completely believable cuz like
one sugar gliders are very trendy pets
for influencers yep
and I totally believe that that that
would shock and upset people mm-hmm but
that app a tuber might do it yeah like
if if the sugar glider was like a huge
character on their show and the sugar
glider passed away they might do that as
like thinking it would be a positive
thing like an homage to their sugar
glider but then it would like completely
shock people I should have been more
like I should have been given that you
tuber more credit saying like they'd
probably know that be a bad PR move but
you don't know how big that youtuber is
some of these like that guy was a GoPro
it was like he had like 11k air you know
yeah it could have been a small channel
that didn't know what they're doing but
reddit or Twitter or Twitter yeah yeah
so this doesn't have to always be big
yeah you're right you're right it is
really hard I had a 50-50 chance odds
have not been my favorite recently I'm
proud of myself for doing so I really
feel fooling you owe more right than on
okay yeah yeah okay you ready yes I
might be above failing grade who knows
okay drama youtuber who's gotten nearly
a hundred million views in 11 months
might not be a real person this is
interesting because I know a lot of a
eyes and like YouTube personalities and
influencers are now digital there's like
an Instagram account yeah like this
Instagram influencer and they have a
YouTube channel now oh really but on
Instagram they have millions and
millions of followers super high
engagement so like mostly realistic 3d
person yeah but it's confusing because
they're often interacting with this is
not what the this is a separate thing
this is like you're not part of the game
yeah this is a real thing that's going
it was a real influencer that is digital
mckaela mckaela oh yeah something like
that yeah and she does brand deals with
like adidas and huge company yeah yeah
so it's like there's a lot of mystery
around it like is she real is she not
really what is going on it turns out
there's a it's a agency like an ad
agency that started and ran her and grew
her and it's all just like people behind
the scenes so read me the title again
drama youtuber who's gotten nearly a
hundred million views in 11 months might
not be a real person so now now that's
confusing to me and a lot of reasons
might not be a real person there has to
be a real person running the channel
right I mean I'm just reading headlines
or do you think that there's like a
computer algorithm that's like I
I think that part could be open to
interpretation okay I think it has to be
it has to be a person a headline oh yeah
yeah oh yeah it's your thing is this
headline true or false
and within that headline there can be
interpretations like yeah there's a team
behind it creating that content and
running it but like the personality that
is the YouTube like like let's say the
personality is like real tea spilled dot
TV or something
and the person's name is tea what's up
mr. G so mr. t is the the personality
and mr. t isn't real it's like a company
that's running it and mr. t spills the
tea
so is this your boss it is true you're
right yes
this one was very interesting to me I
actually like all the other ones I
didn't watch the like videos about it
but this one
there was a video about it and I wash it
because I was like intrigued hmm um so
I'll pull it I'll pull it up here so you
can see it was a spill spill the name
isn't T but the name is spill
so basically hmm there's um there's this
channel that started and there's a lot
of like slow motor oil type channels and
most of them are a lot of them are real
people there are some animated ones um
so this is an animated T drama channel
there was a video by a youtuber called
DeAngelo Wallace who and I I watched his
video and it's super interesting but he
did a video kind of uncovering some of
this mystery
oh wow because so it started with this
channel called spill that's a cute
little animated character with a unlike
a lot of drama channels there's like a
heavy amount of research that goes into
these Wow and there's it's not like
peppered with jokes and funny
things it's just like straight
information very professional voiceover
very nice-looking animations and a ton
of research so you'd think like wow that
would take a long time to do that but
they're uploading like multiple videos a
week Wow
and spill the character talks about
things like her classes and her homework
and stuff like that and so you think you
think that she's like a girl in college
or something like that yeah and she's
like just doing research and relaying
this information in her spare time but
then there was one episode where she's
talking about how she has big homework
assignment due and so she's gonna step
out of this video and her friend brew is
gonna stop step in brew is another
animated character in the same style and
on the Twitter page on spills Twitter
she like links to brew and brew is a
whole nother channel exact same style
spill and blue like brew the tea his um
science based okay so he's a science
youtuber named brew and he's kind of
disheveled looking but same style
animated character very professional
voice-over very well-thought-out videos
multiple week I believe most globocon
that went to I know multiple on spill
and then there's another one another
character that uh sometimes brought in
called grill and I don't know what he
does food-related food and lifestyle
he's angry looking that's grill with the
red shirt and he's got angry eyebrows um
and then he was brought in and whole
another channel and all these channels
have a lot of subscribers and put out a
lot of videos that are very well done
and he has his own thing and so it's
like okay there's gotta be a company
behind all channels that is doing this
and it's gotta be like a huge team to be
researching all this different type of
content doing the animations yeah they
have professional voiceovers but they're
presented as if these are real people
yes that like collab together yeah
essentially and they cross promote each
other's stuff on Twitter but then
[Music]
on the hill and it's a totally animated
story based channel where spill brew and
grill and other characters all go to
school and like so spill saying she's
got homework is the character spill
referring to the story where they're all
animated characters together all have
their own channel referring to it's like
reality yeah it's like oh in our
universe I have homework it's not the
real person behind spill having homework
it's spill the character having homework
in that universe oh my gosh
crazy it's a whole alternate reality
where there's like one of every type of
popular youtuber and they keep popping
up more in building these crazy channels
and then like and then since they have
the academy now like they can use the
academy channel to introduce a new
character who will then launch their own
YouTube channel and they can stay
forever young always in school yep and
because that's like a popular
demographic to be in you know oh my gosh
just go on forever the company can grow
it's not tied to an actual person
that's insane it's smart and scary right
like a crazy concept it's a crazy
concept but it's really smart it was
like all these youtubers going to school
together and they each have their own
specialty and their own channels but the
company maintains full control over the
character because it was a real person
that person might want to renegotiate
their contract they might want to leave
the crew or whatever but like since
they're animated and and anyone can take
it over and anyone can be replaced you
know then people have no control like
even if you're the voiceover force bill
you can be replaced by another character
you know yeah you can be replaced by T
spill might maybe spill graduates yeah
you know comes in maybe they even like
in the beginning they made spill do a go
away video replaced by T you know then
anytime at any time if still leaves if
the voice ever very forcefully yes they
know it's possible they know it's
possible like what if you recall
word your own like going-away video and
you know that's just hanging over your
head
so you can't even negotiate like hey I
am the voice of spill I am important you
know that you can just be replaced like
that yeah bingo-bango that's crazy
that's crazy and this has been like hey
it's like a crazy adventure and some of
these videos like some are like like
spills are like 10 minutes but I believe
brews are like videos crazy these have
to take a really long time Cartoon
Network type stuff yeah except it's like
all related it's all in the same
universe oh my gosh yeah oh all again
I'll put a link to D'Angelo Wallace's
video about it it's so fascinating to me
and his video is really good yeah
craziness right brands are running drama
channels and it's a lot there's a title
of D'Angelo Wallace's video yeah that's
insane and I think that this is like a
broader trend that a lot of real like
independent youtubers have been
concerned about for a long time you know
I mean there's nothing that we can do
and it's not that what these companies
are doing are wrong there's an
opportunity and they're seizing along
opportunity and everything is like
that's totally fine legal and there's
nothing wrong with it I mean it's like
this is how market forces work yeah and
there are some like company YouTube
channels that we really enjoy like the
bone Appetit channel it's a company yeah
I think the reason this is weird is cuz
it's not open about being a company oh
yeah like all these individual channels
and I guess once you discover that on
the hill and you see all them together
then you're like you might be like wait
but all these individual channels are
kind of like presenting as if they're
individuals kind of well there's been a
lot of animators that have been
collaborating and having this organic
flow of things you know like life noggin
and odd ones out and all of these big
youtubers who all live in the same area
and often collaborate so possible if
there were real people and they had a
collaborative channel where there yeah
so like stuff like this has happened
naturally before but not at all with
like the exact same art style the exact
same like a cohesive flow of things
that's all like you know if you have
company that's directing things you can
have a much more organically flowing and
consistent message theme art style and
direction of the whole cohesive thing if
you're there's a whole bunch of
independent ad hoc you know channels
that collaborate every now and then it's
more natural but it's not as consistent
and reliable so awesome awesome Simon's
that you prepared thank you thank you
maybe you can do the next one and I'll
get I guess I'll do the next one
all right thank you so weak I don't have
anything so my thing of the week and
this is something I think you introduced
it to me was it like two weeks ago I
think so around there around there and
as you guys know we have been obsessed
with Minecraft and we're not gonna
choose minecraft again we're not
choosing minecraft again but I'm
choosing something that it is still mine
okay
so Evan surprised me with a Nightmare
Before Christmas texture pack for
minecraft so basically it's like a
Minecraft world and it's all freakin
Nightmare Before Christmas
yeah and it's amazing and it's creepy
and it's like official so it's like
officially sanctioned where they have
all the real music they have the actual
characters they made Halloweentown in
Minecraft you can explore everywhere
Christmas town we found the trees where
you hop into the tree and go to your
warped to Christmas town yeah and
there's more trees to go down we haven't
gone to like Easter or Christmas town
and Halloween town and just kind of like
explored terrain a little bit and
started building our house but it's so
cool it's nice
you just get transported and I didn't I
I don't think I would have expected it
to feel as different you know but it's
like a totally different experience even
things like oh this is what iron looks
like yeah but this texture pack is so
cool and gratifying I'm like oh this is
what rain looks like it's like a whole
new game all over again which is so
strange because I like you know the
rules of that's like it's like the same
mechanics but it's a new game it's like
a sequel almost yeah it's super fun um
and so we've been playing that a little
bit on the over on Twitch no highlights
I've made it to the gaming channel yet
but they will soon
but we've also just been like playing
little bits here and there like before
bed yeah it's like it's approaching the
Halloween time it's late August total
when we go to Lowe's the the Halloween
supplies are out yeah they're outside so
it's acceptable getting into the
Halloween spirit I think it'd be fun
like as we get closer to Halloween to do
like Halloween specials play inside
again ooh play limbo limbo limbo but
also like the night before Christmas and
like some other like scary games I think
yeah we're using into scary games it's
not really that scary but we're
replaying half-life right now over on
Twitch yeah it's not the actual
half-life from 1999 Black Mesa it's a
fan-made remake that was done in 2015 so
the graphics are better but it's really
fun it's really really cool and my pick
of the week is gonna be like so many
things I'll just link to a resource that
has them all but recently on Twitch we
have a main recording that records the
whole thing and streams at all at once
they get to audio and everything but
then we also want to record the game and
we also want to record the video and
when you record the full file at full
resolution it the files are so big like
this camcorder right here that like
we're using for the podcast if we
recorded this podcast the file would be
16 gigabytes so I've been like coming up
with this crazy system of HDMI splitters
and extenders and switches and like HDMI
recorders in OBS and I have this whole
system and now we have three computers
all recording different elements of our
stream and they're all being compressed
so that at the end of it each is only
two and a half gigabytes instead of like
16 gigabytes and it's a lot that goes
into it but if you guys ever need any
like splitters or switchers or HDMI or
anything like that I'll link to a
resource page where we have all of our
favorite technology
all our favorite tools not just for HDMI
and podcasting but for resin and soap
and everything we're kind of building
this big resource over at two places
yeah Amazon influencer page yeah and
where we have all of our favorite
products so we're gonna link that it's
kind of a nice master repository of all
of our favorite things we get asked
about it a lot yeah we'll have links
we'll have links to our thing of the
weeks we'll have links to some of the
stuff we mentioned in the podcast and I
think that might be I could turn wrap it
up well you think baby I think that's a
good thing but thanks for watching
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]